no no no no no no no no no no
No what the heck is going on people use
type glass for washing not neem review
beam review do not listen to this man
for he is just trying to hide the
succulent flavor the sewer our sweetness
and the euphoric sensation of the type
pause I am NOT saying eat the tag pies I
am saying engorge yourself welcome to my
new youtube favorite show of all time
this is an important series that we are
reviewing all the means number one it
could possibly be the greatest mean of
all time this meme means more to me than
any other mean we have previously
discussed because it is my mean my
children yes that's right take a seat
can you do this no you can't unless you
bought my chair 399 by the way we here
we have Logan Paul hey PewDiePie my
merch is better but can you do this
because that's right my sweet children
it is my me this meme started with me
announcing my chair and I was just going
through the basic features of them of
the chair can your chair do this I don't
think so okay
this thing is the goddamn Lamborghini of
chairs it's not a chair it's a lifestyle
that's generous and wonderful I am I had
a nice tutorial of this chair I might
yeah yes yes it is only 399 and I'll
have you let you know but can you do
this I don't think so the meme continued
in brain later episodes of Louie and
from there it just spread like wildfire
it just went left and right can you do
this whenever you hear someone says
something and you go but immediately
reaction is breaking it more addicting
than Derek see here we have men women
deficient right and you can't do this
that's the joke because you can't do it
only they expose exclusive club members
that owned the 399 chair of God can
enjoy this mean properly somebody
touched my spaghetti someone in this
house so you can touch spaghetti with
this me I'm the tallest tower in the
world but gimme Diddy 399 that's a great
price that's a great offer that's a
great price consider yourself lucky
hey look we're on an airplane be needy
excuse me sir I'm gonna have to ask you
to put your chair up today we have these
muscle relaxants I'm gonna put them on
me okay so do we know our part Manor
Park okay first question favorite ways
to relax
[Music]
can you cover the pot three-night yes
get your glass of water that's right
that's right you can't you can't do this
only I can do this get rid of time cook
enough that was a Ugandan spit that's
right then you got an amine really died
out quick
[Music]
humanity has peaked this is it this is
the high point that we've all been
looking for when it comes to the meat
it's never going to be a better me than
this my favorite one is still this one
it's so good so get it's such a funny
wonderful relatable Mimi PewDiePie chair
added to cart three $99.99 very name now
of course people tried they they wonder
hum maybe I can do this so they try and
challenge me sending me stupid images of
fake chairs that's not my chair and I
bet you that chair it's not 399 as
impressive as it may be yes yes they say
yes the chair can do this but no no it
cannot I am sorry sue me ma Sen get that
out hello my name is Yuri I have t-midi
expression mature six feet here and big
babies I can write puns with deep
meaning using complex words and I will
die because I love you but any and it
hey we have incredible fan art from this
mean I look at this pixel art beautiful
we have animations and even more
incredible animations I love this one
we even have songs about can you do this
[Music]
the original of this meme is 100% mine
and it does not come at all at all from
this old mean from like what 2012 where
they say yo you your smartphone think
you're so great huh but can you do this
or maybe then the two DSi you think
you're so great huh but can you do this
ah you snitched classic minhee's think
you're so great huh but can you do this
it even got so far that the creator of
this webcomic had to tweet out that face
when you started making some comics with
the catchphrase but can you do this in
2013 but then weirdly PI uses it and
everybody thinks you're refer
referencing his chair me that's great
and all but this sleeve is mine it is
mine and I've copyrighted it and I was
sitting 6,000 lawyers you're waiting all
night if you want a war then the war you
show hair is noodle nut you maybe you
may talk trash you find my dog you may
take trash about my channel you may not
dress by my girlfriend but you talk
trash about mommy and you look face
just oh yeah now this means to be honest
it's it's a pity pie mean it's not gonna
get a high rating it's immediately two
points let's say it's a 10 out of 10
meat all right Chris remove two points
right off the bag this is beauty pie
related nice remove two points right off
the bat because it's a Normie meme at
this point remove another two point five
points because it has absolutely no
racism sexism suicidal undertones none
of that no problematic undertones it's
actually family-friendly memes to remove
another point
and which leads us to the overall score
of 10 out of 10 this is a 10 out of 10
the first 10 outta 10 mean that we have
ever had and probably ever will
I'm really proud to finally have the
first 10 out of 10 meme on meme review
clap it up everyone we've done it
together we did it 10 out of 10 meet
well done you and well done me here we
are now of course this meme has to die
there's meme is dead okay
oh don't be sad though all means have to
die so don't be too don't be too sad but
I don't want to see this meme why ever
again alright it's gonna be it's gonna
be pretty bad okay I'm gonna get really
angry don't post this meme anymore it's
not funny it had a good life span we
should not take this mean by overusing
it when it's not longer funny it was a
good run everybody it was a good one
give yourself a pat on the back next
skedaddle skedaddle skedaddle skedaddle
your ding dong is now a noodle this mean
is a garbage meat anytime I do it you
laugh you lose someone is posting this
god-awful meme and it just annoys the
hell out of me and this is a
[Music]
this is the worst meme I have ever
encountered in my entire life
hey look it's a it's a you life you lose
thread oh that's that's that's great
that's great let's see what oh look it's
this one it's so funny every time I
watch it it gets better stop it I'm
saying stop it now before anyone gets
hurt
[Music]
[Music]
stop stop it stop this is the worst meme
I have ever encountered in my life I'm
rating this that's right a samra garbage
me I don't accept I spit on it
this week's bonus meme everybody clap it
up we have time for it
lucky you pop team epoch or pup-pup tap
epic it's a manga that has now come out
as an anime it's not really memes from
the manga it's more the sense that the
manga is a meme itself isn't the red
collar wonderful so you can hide the
colour of blood with this the hybrid car
is very quiet right so you can kill
without making yourself
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
check out pop team epic it's basically
an anime turned into one big [ __ ] post
it's beautiful I couldn't recommend it
enough it's not hashtag spawn or
anything it's more like if you're
probably gonna see this appearing here
and there and now thanks to me your
fellow mean review person you can be
like aha I know where that's that's from
this mean it's not really memes so I'm
just gonna give it a seal of approval
everybody that was snitch which may
review everybody clap it up which one
was your favorite me let me know in the
comments down below what do you want me
to review next and remember to keep on
smiling everybody
[Music]